Induction and
deduction are critical topics to
understand in machine learning.
So let's pause for a moment and go over
them in more detail with a segment from
Ashok's and
my Artificial Intelligence course.
Note especially, that machine
learning is largely about induction.
>> Let us look at
abduction more closely.
To understand the similarities and
difference between deduction,
abduction and induction,
let us look at the relationship
between a rule, cause and effect.
Let's consider a simple rule
like if it is cloudy, it rains.
So it is cloudy is the cause,
it rains is the effect.
If it is cloudy,
then it rains is the rule.
>> Other example of a rule would
be the rule that Bob hates Joe.
So Bob hates Joe, so
whenever Joe walks in, Bob Leaves.
The cause is Joe walking in,
the effect is Bob leaving, and
the rule is Bob hates Joe.
>> You've already come across yet
another instance of this particular
arrangement when we were
talking about flu and fever.
So the rule might be,
if flu, then fever.
Flu is the cause, fever is the effect.
Now in deduction, in one fundamental
kind of inference we know the rule and
the cause and
we need to deduce the effect.
So given the rule if it is cloudy,
then it rains and
given the cause it is cloudy
we can deduce that it rains.
>> Similarly,
in our rule that Bob hates Joe,
we can say that if Joe just walked in,
we can deduce that Bob will leave.
>> Or if the rule is,
if flu, then fever, and
we know that Ashck has flu,
then we can deduce that Ashok has fever.
This is simply an instance
of modus ponens and
we discussed this in detail when
we were talking about logic.
Now let us look at induction.
Given a relationship between a cause and
an effect, we can try to induce a rule.
For example, if we observe repeatedly
that when it is cloudy, it rains.
It may be induce a rule.
If it is cloudy, then it rains.
>> Same thing with Bob and Joe.
If we observe repeatedly that
every time Joe arrives Bob leaves,
we can induce a rule
that Bob must hate Joe.
>> If every time a patient
goes to a doctor with flu and
a patient has fever, then we can
induce a rule, if flu, then fever.
In case of abduction, given a rule and
an effect, we can abduce a cause.
As an example, given the rule,
if it is cloudy, then it rains, and
the effect that it is raining,
we can ask ourselves, is it cloudy?
>> And once again with Bob and Joe,
given our rule that Bob hates Joe and
given that we just arrived at a party
and we see that Joe is here but not Bob,
we might be able to abduce that
Bob left when Joe arrived.
>> Or given the rule, if flu then fever
and the fact that Ashok has fever,
we might be able to abduce
that Ashok has flu.
First of all,
notice that we are back to diagnosis.
Diagnosis as an instance of abduction.
But notice several other properties.
First, deduction is truth preserving.
If the rule is true, and
a cause is true, we can always guarantee
that the effect is true as well.
Induction and
abduction are not truth preserving.
You may know something about the
relations between cause and effect for
some sample, that does not mean that
the same relationship holds for
the entire population.
Induction does not always guarantee
correctness, same for abduction.
We may know the rule and the effect and
we may suppose that the cause is true
but that need not necessarily be true.
It may be the case, if flu,
then fever and Ashok may have fever But
that does not necessarily
mean that Ashok has flu.
Fever can be caused by many,
many things.
The reason that fever does not
necessarily mean that Ashok has flu is
because there can be multiple causes for
the same effect, multiple hypothesis for
the same data.
This is exactly the problem
that we had encountered earlier
when we were talking about
what makes diagnosis hard.
We said that deduction, induction, and
abduction are three of
the fundamental forms of inference.
We can of course also
combine these inferences.
Science is a good example.
You and I are scientists,
observe some data about the world.
Then we abduce some explanation for it.
Having abduced that explanation for
it, we induce a rule.
Having induced a rule, now we can use
deduction to predict new data elements.
We go and observe some more.
Again, we abduce, induce,
deduce and we continue the cycle.
Might the cycle also explain
significant part of cognition.
Is this what you and I do on a daily
basis, abduce, induce, deduce?
>> In machine learning,
what we're largely interested
in doing is induction.
Taking some data in which we speculate
cause and effect relationship exist and
inducing a rule.
The rule actually need to be causal,
it's a right of the rule's
about correlation.
The important thing is inducing a rule
that will allow us to make sense of data
in the future.
That rule can then be applied
deductively or abductively.
In trading, for example,
we might apply that rule deductively
to protect what stocks will gain value.
Or abductively to decide where
insider trading has already occurred.
So now that you have
a good grasp of induction,
let's get back to Charles and Michael.